this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author of the
book redefining anxiety is my co-host
today as we talk about mental health
issues money issues life issues and all
by the way it all goes together because
by god it's thanksgiving week so here we
go it is thanksgiving game on the
beautiful part about thanksgiving is you
get to see your family and the crazy
part about thanksgiving week is you get
to see your family open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
as we talk about life and money right
here
on the ramsey show before we get out of
the hour i'm not gonna do it right now
but just be thinking about this i'm
gonna come to you and you're gonna give
us some advice for dealing with
thanksgiving oh man all of us yeah we'll
just get some clinical advice we'll just
have a little counseling session for
america this time tomorrow i'm gonna be
in a deer blind in the woods that's
about as good as i can give but oh
avoidance is your turn it's in hiding
and this is your technique that's right
that's right
i'll give you some i'll give you some
good ideas okay there we go all right i
like it i'm in all right we'll start
this hour off with renee in portland
oregon hey renee what's up
hi dave
um can you hear me yes ma'am
so
we
got
some insurance money
for a really bad reason and
um
we lost our our little girl and so we're
having a hard time
you know knowing
what is the best thing to do with this
at this point
um from my perspective i would like to
relocate closer to family and from his
perspective he would like to not blow it
because our income is not hot right now
um and
that's basically where we're at we used
a little bit of it to finish from
of the debt snowball um but we'd be left
with
um
100k in student loans um 200 in our
house
and
30 left over from
the money
my goodness
how long ago did you lose your daughter
it was last uh
june 20 20.
um
that terrible year
yeah
um so it's been
yeah it's just hard to do and you know
my husband told me last night he's like
there's no way i do i do not want to put
her money
on
those
you know
um
you know i can hear another kid you got
other uh other little ones obviously got
a little baby right yeah
yeah yeah we got a baby here and a
two-year-old how old was your daughter
she was two she was two what was her
name
clara clara
what was it a car wreck or what
uh
we were crossing
the street and
she was stopped i thought i saw her wave
um but i couldn't see her very well she
says she didn't see us
oh man i'm so sorry so that that's
accurate but yeah
so the insurance check is how much
it was 50. 50 000
yes
and that actually was not from her
insurance that was from our insurance
for underinsured motorists so we did not
find any document
um
i guess for our pursuing her still isn't
not on the table but
um
anyway
here's the thing okay the
horrible tragedy you've been through is
a 20 on a scale of one to ten
okay
what you do with the money
is a one
on a scale of one to ten
okay and you guys are equating
especially your husband is with the
statement he made you're equating the
use of this money somehow
the weight of the use of the money
you're weighing it the same as
the tragedy and they're not even on the
same planet
it's just 50 000 it doesn't even
matter come in comparison to what your
all's hearts have been through
and if you try to make the expense if
you set it in the middle of the floor
and burn it it doesn't change anything
right
and if you want to equate the gravity of
this 50 like what you spend this on
it's got to equal the weight of the
importance of our little baby girl that
will that that math will never work
yeah
yeah how long ago did you get this check
um recently like a few months ago what's
your household income
um we're
about 38 a year i think
did you say you were thinking of
relocating did i hear you say that
earlier uh yeah i would we're kind of
off here he's it's an hour commute from
his work which in today's
crazy house live on the street where the
accident occurred
no
okay
it's down the corner down the road okay
that's good
um
so you're thinking of reach do you own
the home you're in
it's we have 2k on it
yeah what wait no 200 oh that's right
you said you had a mortgage so you do
own it but it has a mortgage on it so
take that take the money out of here
take and take the tragedy away
was you got two little kids is were you
intending to steer your family back
closer towards family
i would
love to this is kind of where we found
something
in our budget um and we thought oh our
drive it's not that big of a deal
um
bonkers for 38 000 a year
yeah feels heavy yeah i wouldn't make an
hour drive for 138 000 a year
so um i wouldn't make it period but uh
not enough money on the freaking planet
but yeah it's not it's not like he's got
the dream job of all jobs it's worth
driving an hour for especially with you
guys having gone through this so i'm
either changing jobs or i'm making a
move uh as far as this money goes here's
a good idea don't do anything with it
right now
just put it in a cd for a year
it is not going to change your life
it doesn't clean up all your debt it
doesn't make anything here easy it's not
5 million
which if it was that we talk about
trying to push through maybe and try to
figure out something of what was some
basic things to go on but 50 000 i don't
want to belittle the amount of money but
in comparison to what's all going on in
your life
i wouldn't even have this discussion no
i would just set it to the side be in
denial about it about the money for a
little bit and then then you guys start
talking about making your decisions
about your move yeah because the
decisions are getting wound up in the
brief and the right and then it becomes
about this money
yeah decide whether you're going to move
or not decide we're going to get a new
job but my husband doesn't have to be
gone two hours a day for 38 000 bucks
and here's the thing i'll put some words
in his mouth he didn't call
he said he couldn't spend her money on
this
honey it's not her money
she's in heaven
it's your money
now how are you going to live your life
with your current family after this
heartbreak
so
if you're gonna treat it like her money
just go give it to the church or
something and walk away
but it's really not her money it's one
that came because of a horrible
unbelievable breathtaking tragedy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
do
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five
five
two two five
so john uh
i i think it's worth revisiting our last
call because it's such a horrible
situation such an unusual situation
um
the data around
the statistical averages around people
losing a child
for any reason accident disease anything
else but particularly an accident um
the marriage data is not good yeah it's
tough it's not friendly
the um a lot of people lose their
marriages uh they can't process one of
the two or both can't process through
the grief together
um i suppose that's what it is um
and um
i can't wrap my head around
what happened there well i mean i guess
there was just an accident there was no
one at fault
quote unquote how there's only a fifty
thousand dollar check involved yeah
there should be i would i kind of would
think there's no money
or there's
a bazillion dollars if you ever see
those actuary tables of
what you know you lose a limb you lose
somebody this age you lose somebody that
age and it all comes back it's it's a
heartbreaking actuary table to look at
what was my
you know dismemberment worth what was my
death worth here is the death oh here's
what the quote-unquote
economic economic value right and so
it's this gross it's just gross the
whole thing's yuck yeah and it's the
insurance companies just trying to put
it put a dollar on it but to go back to
your statement
we grieve everybody grieves so
differently that ultimately you get a
clash you often have a
a clash of grief somebody wants somebody
to move on and somebody wants someone to
feel this different and it just causes a
split in a marriage and you really have
to be intentioned by grieving together
and giving space for each other and
so many times the language of money is
where our emotions
find their words yeah
um
and so when he says we're not if we
can't blow her money and stuff like that
that sets off alarm bells in my head
mine too uh because the uh
i don't wanna move and so i've gotta
i've got an excuse
well or
i mean i
i i you know it's hard to know because
i've never been in this situation but i
can't drive down that street anymore no
no can't drive down the street my throat
is just in my
my my stomach's in my throat talking
about it and i don't even know these
people that's right you know but uh so i
can't even imagine now uh i mean i still
drive by
exits where
you know uh just by an exit where i knew
a guy that lived up there you know and i
have an emotion you know it's like
that kind of a thing because i've been
in the same city my whole life yeah and
so each of these intersections has some
kind of a memory to it you know and so i
pulled over there yeah yeah
i went to jail there when i was 16 you
know whatever but yeah but the uh uh
i can't imagine having that kind of a
no thing associated with a street and
this is unique because normally you have
a major tragedy
and there's a you know it in the next
couple of months things work themselves
out and you get you've got to face some
of these what i call the nuts and bolts
realities like here's the dollar amount
where's the funeral who's who's making
the the
you know the invitations whatever
this is different because her their
daughter passed away in june of 2020 and
they just got the check last week right
and i still think your your wisdom was
right i still think
you put it away for six months nine
months and you let that
we gotta heal the money's gonna stay
here because if we just go jump on
something it's usually gonna be
something out of emotion well if if she
goes and does with it what she wanted
and he feels like they blew
her
her money
that's a that's a violation you're never
going to get he could never look at her
again yeah that that begins a process
that's not and if wife feels like
husband is holding this money our baby's
money hostage and is forcing me down the
same road every week and forcing me to
relive this thing where that driver was
my daughter and i were walking across
you gotta relive that all the time
that can that can feel your abusive
right and so it's putting this money
away and
what are we going to decide about our
life right now like what are we going to
do now let's live our life then let's
come back to this money right after our
brains have cleared a little bit of some
of the grief fog yeah yeah the in levi
said it's the fog of grief the grief's
gonna be there man
she will find herself stronger
and she will have different life
experiences but that moment that's that
moment's there it's trauma in his stage
that's right that's right yeah that's
that's true but you do get you're you're
you become resilient you get stronger
well your critical thinking skills get
better and better and better the further
you are from the event yeah assuming
you're healing right right yeah that's
your only shot at it and that's why we
tell people like for instance a spouse
we've been married uh 51 years you know
and he left me a million dollars worth
of life insurance what do i do i don't
know what to do i've never handled the
money before i don't know
and he died a week ago you know that
kind of a thing i always tell that widow
or widower in that case to park it
freeze park it for a year if you can
survive without the money and eat just
park it and eat and cry yeah and get get
past some of that
some of it and uh get to the point that
you can come back wow
open phones this is the ramsey show dr
john dolone my co-host the phone number
here triple eight eight two five
five two two five travis is in lima ohio
lima ohio hi travis how are you
how you doing thank you for taking my
call sure lima or lima
lima lima okay good i got it right now
lima like the bean what's that like the
bean ramsay come on all right what's up
yeah yeah so i make about forty thousand
dollars a year i have twenty thousand
dollars in savings with a thousand
dollar emergency fund uh i'm planning on
uh i have a question of i should have
about thirty thousand dollars in
february march and i'm thinking about
putting a down payment on a house
or if i should wait for a couple years
to put a bigger down payment on a house
to
almost pay it off within 15 years or
should i just go ahead and put a down
payment on a house now next year and pay
it off
with uh with the next couple years of
working
well there's nothing rushing you uh i
didn't hear anything in the discussion
that's rushing you how old are you
it's 20. oh you said 20 i'm sorry did
you live at home
i live with my grandparents i'm paying
them rent uh they want me out in
february that's why good
good for them yeah i like your grandpa
okay that's why i want to see if i
should rent for a couple of years and
just almost pay off the house
anybody
no i'm single okay you going to school
i'm trade i was on trade school i don't
have any debt i
don't have any card loans or anything
for trade school what are you studying
i do welding i already graduated i have
a full-time job i make military things
oh okay i know boy travis good job man
all right so here's the deal uh yeah you
can go and buy a house if you want or
you can wait either one you're in good
enough shape financially uh you're young
enough it would be okay to go rent for a
year
there's nothing wrong with that and use
that year to build up even some more
cash no harm in that either you would
only be 21 when you bought your house
and that's still very young
um
and and you know there's no
you know there's no harm in that no harm
in buying a house when you're young but
there's nothing that says you're
brilliant for doing it young i will tell
you as a young single guy
that when you meet that lady and marry
her you will discover you have purchased
the wrong home
and you'll get to move again and you
decorated it terribly yeah well we know
that
for sure you didn't decorate it but um i
mean where did you get this furniture
but um yeah that's that's gonna happen
but that's okay that's nothing in the
world you can sell it and move again
and make some money on it i suppose
right is the market there fairly good
can you move a house
yeah it's pretty high i was just
wondering because i know you said like
this is kind of like the 2008 era
of the house market and obviously
opposite yeah yeah travis if i'm you
brother i would rent for a year i would
let somebody else fix my sink in my
shower where i just hustled and ground
grind it out and pile up some money made
a bunch of money let the market you
might you might purchase a different
house after you've been a renter for a
year than you would purchase now yeah i
think you'll gain some wisdom that's
what i would do but yeah feel free man i
think i would
neither one we're going to put you in
the stupid column okay
but um but i think probably a little bit
wiser would be your last rent
i like the idea of being old enough to
buy champagne on the day you buy your
house that sounds good right
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage kelsey and robbie are
with us hey guys how are you okay
welcome where do you all live dallas
texas ah welcome to nashville happy week
of thanksgiving
good to have you and up here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off 44
900
all right and how long did that take 26
months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh 91 000 up to
103
and then down to 81 000. cool all right
what do you guys do for a living
i'm a veterinary assistant
and i'm a product manager and back-end
developer for a mobile gaming company ah
good for you good so what kind of debt
was this 45 grand
it was mostly mine uh student loan debt
uh just a couple thousand of medical
mm-hmm okay how long you all been
married seven years
seven years so five years into your
marriage almost
four and a half years something happened
and you decided we're going to check out
this ramsey stuff tell us your ramsey
story what happened well uh our daughter
who's here with us was born
plans around her birth kind of changed
and so we had to kind of
come together and refocus some things
i'm the nerd she's the free spirit and
so
trying to figure out like how to get her
on board with things is kind of like the
first start of everything but she's
ultimately the one that was like
okay i've been listening to you know
ramsay on podcast and everything
we need to get you know serious and
focused and i was like all right finally
like you know let's let's go let's do it
that's accurate
so uh how did you find us on the radio
robert
oh so uh we we kind of always knew about
you my parents had hosted some financial
piece university classes growing up so
it was a financial piece baby
but we finally took it seriously and
stopped being fake adults and
got with it what happened around the
birth
well so we had planned for a home birth
and had gone through all the steps of
doing that
and how long were you in labor
three days three days um so ultimately
we had to go to yeah it's time to go to
the hospital yeah yeah which we uh about
three days before that yeah yeah
yeah oh my gosh yeah so uh so insurance
doesn't pay for hospital birth so we
paid of that for that up front and then
we had to still turn around and go to
the hospital so it's like we paid double
oh wow um and so when we got that bill
we were uh you know it was like ah and
then and then i you know got sick a few
months later and had we had to go back
to the hospital and then um so it was
just like you know everything was just
piling up and yeah
yeah there's a snowball in the wrong
direction yeah yeah well you got the
stress but you also have the new birth
which always wakes you up and goes uh
this just got real i got to get serious
now the first baby does that it kind of
gives you the wake-up call right
definitely yeah way to go you guys 45
000 boom 2 000 a month 26 months later
you're done
yeah
one thing we uh wanted to talk about
during the um
during the whole process of the 26
months uh the reason our income had gone
up and gone down was because we did some
side hustles uh he did pizza delivery
like you always recommend and did that
um
you know so he didn't have any days off
for about six or seven months wow we
also did um dog boarding in our home so
like all of this past summer we had as
many as nine dogs in our house
but everybody wanted to get out and go
on vacation this summer uh you know
things were opening up so yeah you were
happy to take their money uh
yes and so we did that um i also uh when
our income went back down that's due to
i had a career change so i decided
during covet that i didn't want to be in
sales anymore i wanted to go back to
school to do my passion which is
veterinary work so
i'm a veterinary assistant right now i
work at a vet's office and i'm in school
to become a licensed veterinary nurse oh
wow so and we're cash flowing that yeah
very good very good okay what was the
best month of dog boarding what's the
most money you made in a month dog
boarding oh my gosh uh uh there's a
picture up there
um so
i think well i don't know about a full
month but over like june july august we
made uh three thousand dollars
yeah so like a thousand dollars a month
okay what was your best month delivering
pizza
um probably close to that i mean yeah
nothing really
miraculous happened it was just you know
determination and focus
yeah another thing grind oh yeah another
thing that like uh was a bump in the
road was um
was it last summer yeah so
it was actually like closer to the
spring of 2020 like right after things
started shutting down yeah our ac unit
went out of course of course it did yeah
yeah um but that was right when the
first relief was coming in plus we had a
little bit in our account and we were
able to cash flow
an entire new ac unit because of this
program which is crazy right well before
that before that um you know every when
that happened it was going to be like 12
000 to get a new ac for our house and
everybody was telling us just get a
credit card and you can pay it off and
this and that and we were just really
firm with no we're not doing that we
will live through the summer in texas
without air conditioning because we are
not getting another credit card to do
that um so that when the um government
relief came in i felt like that was just
a blessing that we were trusting the
plan and it came at just the right time
and we were able to negotiate a cash
deal
much less
yes yeah yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
uh stick to the plan and follow it
do the baby steps yeah you're gonna have
to say yes he has to say no to a lot of
things but ultimately that'll allow you
to say yes to a lot of things was it
worth it
definitely yeah will you go back in debt
no
they were ready they were ready to walk
through a texas summer with no air
conditioning people say i was ready to
walk through hell that's not as hot as a
texas summer with no air conditioning so
man y'all are ready to go through it
yeah i'm proud of you wait guys way to
go heroes well done we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story to go on and
become baby steps millionaires you're on
your way to do that and a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone pay it forward and uh
maybe they can start their journey like
you guys did so very very proud of you
and you brought your daughter what is
her name and age her name is autumn and
she's three all right
ready for a debt-free scream from texas
she's beautiful look at that look at her
cute as a button that's fun all right
it's autumn kelsey and robbie from
dallas texas 45 000 paid off in 26
months making 91 to 103 to 81. lots of
side hustles count it down let's hear a
debt free scream all right three two one
[Applause]
look at that that's how you change your
family tree right there autumn she's not
old enough that she will remember this
but she will have now grown up in a
family
that doesn't borrow money and i grow up
in a family that goes on to become
wealthy and grow up in a family that has
outrageous generosity because they have
the means to be outrageous and goes up
in a family that knows for seven or
eight months we can do anything grows up
in a house where mom says you know what
i'm worth more than going to a job that
i hate i'm going to do something that i
love and i'm going to put in the time
and effort she's going to grow up with
totally a totally different ethos in
that home mm-hmm you know what i mean
the babies have all changed in the last
30 months yeah i mean in the middle of
it yeah in the middle of all the stuff
you know and you still got to make these
decisions and go
all right texas heat bring it on
god says okay i got your back a strange
conversation with a therapist one day
thinking saying i have these memories of
dogs everywhere
her therapist will make up some
ridiculous response but
it was true but it actually it was true
that's how mom and dad got out of decks
it was the summer we made three grand
with nine dogs dogs and pizza everywhere
yeah
dogs eating pizza
congratulations y'all
oh fun stuff
very fun well that's how you do it folks
you just uh set your mind to it
and you set aside what other people
think and you say i'm gonna endure
whatever i have to endure for a short
period of time no discipline seems
pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
here at ramsey solutions we are on a
mission to transform so many lives that
we disrupt this toxic culture
what's that mean well imagine a world
where it's weird to have a student loan
imagine a world where it's normal to pay
cash for your car imagine a world where
the credit card is the cigarette of the
financial world
because it is
imagine a world where people were
working jobs
that they love
because of ken coleman's materials
imagine a world where people were able
to have quality relationships and less
anxiety because they were hanging out
with dr john deloni's material and so on
hey
imagine what it'd be like to be a part
of the team that's causing all that to
happen we've got a little over a
thousand folks about 1060 working here
today and we create digital products and
services that transform people's lives
it's absolutely
happening if you want to join this
crusade we're on the hunt for some
developers
dev wants to have tuesday of threes
if you're a ux designer or seo or
content marketing specialist or data
analyst
yeah we've got a about 500 people just
like you here and
that are very smart and we'd love to
have you join that team we've got a lot
of things happening here and when you
write a line of code here
it actually changes somebody's life find
out about the positions that are open at
ramseysolutions.com
careers ramsey solutions dot com slash
careers our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal all
right today's question comes from becky
in pennsylvania becky writes i found out
six weeks ago that my husband has been
cheating on me for most of our marriage
i confronted him about this and we're
both seeing counselors at our church
my husband is very repentant and
realizes he needs help we sold our small
business changed his phone number and
email he took a pay cut by taking a new
job or he has accountability and is not
working by himself
last night we tried to do our budget
meeting and it did not end well i feel
like he's very controlling in our
finances and i don't trust him at all
yet should we dip into our emergency
fund to help pay for the counseling or
use the money from selling the business
to help us get through this time
dave what
you go first
nope i'll go first i feel like something
i feel like this blew up and they
responded to a blow up with another blow
up and they're making a bunch of real
quick snap decisions
and they're sprinting and sprinting
trying to catch up with a problem they
just need to stop for a minute turn all
the lights on and say hey that that
party is over we need to figure out
where we're at
yeah
um
okay
yeah that would not be a bad first step
and yes you spend money on counseling
before you spend money on hanging on
you're not gonna have to hang on he got
a job shut up
you can hang on um
so
um
what i look for in these things and
sadly
in doing financial coaching one-on-one
trying to do the budget and you just
can't get the budget to work
and you can't get them to work together
and the more you force into it the more
you figure out something is going on
that's not showing up here on the paper
it's hard to put girlfriend as a line
item in a budget
yes it really doesn't work well and when
you actually have money going out over
here to secret life
then your budget's not going to balance
and if you're controlling
and you're having a power play on the
budget
i'm always suspicious
that
he's not back to his old tricks um
gotcha that's why he blew up gotcha
because she was calling him out because
the money's not the money's not showing
up where's the money and girlfriend's
not an acceptable line on the budget uh
for most wives huh you know for most
you know it just doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't work for most people so
um that's uh uh
yeah and so usually when
someone particularly the husband is
extremely controlling
on the money
there's other control issues in the
relationship there's other deceptions in
the relationship there's other things it
can be the la the wife too if she's just
an overbearing you know test pilot for a
broom factory
same thing going on right i read that
this way that he got busted it's a big
deal it all blows up and the response
was well then we're selling everything
you're getting a new job you're doing
this you're doing this you're doing this
you're doing this and he kind of got to
the end of it and he got he goes i've
repented enough i'm not i'm not
but it's over the budget right well the
budgetary controlling of our finances
that i'm just i don't know we're reading
it we're reading into an email we don't
have any idea but it reminds me of it
reminds me of you know high school
on an english class you can kind of get
to your answer
math class it was
there was one right answer and you can
it's not an essay question all right you
can fudge your way through now we're on
the same page we're doing good we're
doing good that budget says are you in
are you out and neither of them i don't
think are in here
yeah
neither of them she's got yes to answer
your question you can't afford
let's spend a little bit of money on
counseling before we spend a lot of
money on divorce court i agree
so yes i agreed and spent a little bit
of money on counseling and you won't
even miss it because everything else
will start to work right if the
counseling is working right right so um
i feel like he's very controlling
warning sign i do not trust him at all
yet well you shouldn't right yet
uh the way trust is recovered is with uh
lengthy periods of time of being
trustworthy right worthy of trust right
now what we have is a lengthy period of
time of not being worthy of trust so you
would be insane
you would be insane to trust him he
hasn't been trustworthy his whole this
whole man that's what i mean yeah so why
would you suddenly start trusting him
because he repented and that we went to
two counseling sessions of the church no
you wouldn't be you wouldn't be a sane
human being if you trusted him based on
that it takes a little while to recover
that and the old marriage you had is
over period well you didn't really have
one right you didn't have one but what
you thought was theirs over
the way forward is the fantasy you
thought you had not to get back to what
you had you got to recreate something
new you got to reimagine it re-envision
it rebuild something new you can do it
together and make it strong and
beautiful and great and wonderful all
those things but you got to know we're
we're going this way we're not going to
be able to reclaim what was so i'll tell
you this i i feel like and i'm old and
i've walked with a whole bunch of
friends and
other people uh through this process of
divorce and this process of bankruptcy
both and i tell people in both of those
instances i have never with the
exception of domestic violence i've
never told someone you need to get a
divorce right uh and i've never told
someone they need to file bankruptcy uh
because i don't want them following you
because dave ramsey said that
no you need to make that's a big girl
big boy decision you make on your own
not because somebody told you and made
it okay that's right uh and the only
thing i will tell you on either one
both are life-changing
tragedies
and anyone who minimizes either
is full of crap
they're both horrible to go through
bankruptcy divorce
so
that's one of the reasons i don't give
people the dave ramsey permission to do
that you get to make your own permission
i'll still be your friend if you go
through it i'm not gonna be mad at you
but uh you're not gonna do it because i
said uh i'm gonna give you that
authority so you have to make your own
big girl and then the other thing i
always tell you is
if you get to the end of this and you
have done
everything you can try
and then one more thing
you won't live with regret right
i look back on filing bankruptcy
almost 30 years ago now
and i'm not proud of it it is still a
mark of shame
but as a 28 year old kid at the time
after fighting it for two and a half
years my tank was empty intellectually
spiritually emotionally i got babies in
the house i was scared i didn't know
what to do i had done everything i knew
to do and then i waited another two
months
and so i don't look back on that and go
that guy was weak of character and just
walked out i did everything i knew how
to do my level of regret for that is
almost zero right so my ability to
forgive myself and move on is really
high that's right and that's what you
want if you're going to do with this
divorce
you want to have tried everything so yes
try the counseling yes try to meet with
the church yes try all that but bozo's
got a long track record of being a bozo
here right he's not an honest person
hasn't it it's not go you know so you
got a long hill to climb
for him to be trustworthy and for you to
trust him
and uh very controlling over our
finances warning warning warning
just reading between the lines on an
email
that's what we do here on the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john dolone ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and about your money open phones here at
triple eight eight two five
five
two two
five jim is with us in kansas city hi
jim welcome to the ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen i gotta say
that bumper music you had a second ago
there entire straights money for nothing
really enjoying
that thanks brother how can we help
hey i tell you what it's been a rough
year um
god is good
and uh he blesses us but i lost both my
parents about a month and a half ago to
cove but within a week of each other oh
my gosh i'm sorry
67. geez
puppies man pretty tough pretty tough
but
you know
my parents
blessed my wife and i
they prepared and they blessed us with a
little bit of an inheritance
trying to figure it out
so just the short story
my dad had a hundred thousand dollar
annuity through southern baptist
convention
mom had a hundred thousand dollar 401 k
through her work
and i am now the beneficiary and my
understanding is
that they will now be moved into a
beneficiary
401k that has to be distributed within
10 years correct and i'm not sure how to
do that based off of
my wife and i make about 150 grand a
year and so we're concerned about the
tax implications because it is
considered
income yes what are your suggestions
uh all of that information is correct
the law was passed about 18 months ago
there used to be an inherited ira you
could drag it out a lot longer inherited
401 k um the government decided they
wanted to get their tax money out of
your hide even faster and so they now
have a 10-year plan for you
and
so what i would do is just sit down with
your investment advisor if you don't
have one click smart vester pro at
ramseysolutions.com
and the smart investor pro can sit down
with you and put this stuff you can roll
it all into an inherited ira
uh which is fine for they're all the
same thing and just put it in some good
mutual funds and then basically you're
gonna take out a tenth every year
and you're in your growth
and then that would be taxable so if i
make 150 grand a year and basically a
hundred thousand dollars at
you know
10
per year add another 10 to 20 000 bucks
to your income every year
that would be better than to pull it all
out at once and then started a roth ira
with it yes
because about the only thing we're sure
about tax law is it's going to change
okay just depending on which set of
crazies is up there
okay sounds good yeah the crazy left is
going to tax you into oblivion the crazy
right is going to try to figure out a
way to undo it
so um it's just you know it's just gonna
be something all the time
i mean the trump tax laws that passed
were the most bizarre
wonderful things i've ever seen for
keeping their hands off of my money and
but they were bizarre i mean i've never
seen anything like it in my adult years
and they were fairly quiet about it
nobody talked about it because nobody
wanted to give me credit i guess i don't
know but then the biden's been going
through there with a pen and a machete
and changing it back so and any and even
more so so including this law
so um i don't i don't know
i'm just going to take it as slow as i
can take it is what i want to do i'm
going to keep the government's hands off
of it as long as i can keep their hands
off of it because you don't need the
money and let's let that what would be
tax money of this like if you pull
twenty thousand bucks out let's call
three thousand of it tax dollars or six
thousand other tax dollars that's six
thousand dollars if you had left it in
there that is the government's money
ultimately that would have been growing
you money
but now you're going it's not going to
grow you any money because you're going
to send it up there
so you want to take it as slow as you
can take it that's the moral of the
story
good question we appreciate you joining
us open phones at eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
uh let's go to mar in cleveland ohio hey
mar how are you
hey dave hey hi john how you guys doing
great man what's up hey so uh my job is
offerings uh i'm in a new company i
started like a week ago um they're
offering a cash savings benefit plan for
retirement
uh they do have a 401k but they don't um
like contribute to that as you know if
we just had the 401k we'll just you know
put our own money into it uh i did talk
to a financial
pro he told me uh two five since i
already have
a roth ira and i know you teach
matt should be draw for offbeat
tradition
should i just
try to
put money into my rap ra
instead of what
instead of the cash balance by benefit
plan that my job is offering
okay is the job the benefit the cash
balance plan are you required to put
money into it
um they said uh they would match three
percent and we can match two percent
after a year and only in the cash
balance plan
yes only only in the cash balance what
do you do for a living
i'm a truck driver sir is this a union
plan
i don't think they are okay all right
well you would know if you were union
dude
okay well no i'm sorry we're not getting
it no we're not unions but okay
um once again it doesn't make sense i
don't know what that is
he explained to me what a cash balance
uh
it's a defined benefit plan it's just
very unusual and honestly it's very
old-fashioned
it's very 1960s
um and i haven't even heard of one and i
don't know when
uh that's why i'm thinking so basically
a defined benefit plan is simply they
are running a pension plan that they are
largely funding and they are controlling
it they and the easy way to think about
it is the name tells you it is they are
defining
the benefits
you're not
it's a defined benefit plan
and the
cash balance portion of it is just the
calculation of how they're defining the
benefits but
it's oh it's uber conservative at best
like gonna pay five percent maybe maybe
six percent with the regulations that
are on it and so um i'm not putting any
money in it if they put money in it
great but i'm not putting any money in
it just to get the match in other words
it sucks so bad that you getting a three
percent match doesn't make it not suck
that's a better way of saying it so i
just move on
that's that's that's just the simple way
of saying it but right so go ahead and
do your own thing with a roth ira or if
they have a 401k do that and someday
maybe they'll come around and do a match
but yeah if you'll load your roth ira
and if you're married load your wife's
roth ira for the rest of your life
you'll be rich
because you're a young dude you've got
plenty of time
it's so bad i won't even take your money
but that
that's really mathematically what it's
going to come out to be
yeah so there you go this is the ramsey
chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr locke dr john deloney is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two
well christmas is coming
turns out it's in december of this year
they didn't move it
and i love christmas and consequently it
is required if you work at ramsay that
you love christmas because ramsay
solutions we're just christmas people
we're in a christmas frame of mind one
way we celebrate christmas is with our
ramsay show listeners
by giving you
cash it's become a tradition we give
away 500 a week and a grand prize of
five thousand bucks we've already
started doing it we've already had some
winners and you can enter every day no
purchase necessary to increase your
chances of winning you just go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway
ramseysolutions.com that's where you
find everything about ramsey by the way
and
you know you can sign up every day for
your 500 a week that we're giving away
and we're not giving it to everybody
we're giving it to one person so we have
to do a drawing and so you have to be in
the drawing if you're looking for
life-changing gifts for your family or
friends you can check out our week-long
black friday sale in the store at
ramseysolutions.com
up to 73 off best sellers including a
bunch of our best-selling books at 10
including the total money makeover
rachel's brand new new york times
bestseller know yourself know your money
ten dollars
you know what that is a stocking stuffer
yeah a big stocking for these books but
it's okay
this year forget the uh one and by the
way we actually have them in stock and
we will ship them now
uh we don't have a supply chain issue
because we uh heard about supply chain
stuff and went ahead and got stuff extra
in so we were ready for christmas and
stuff
and our
shipping team is
feels like it's important to get it to
you and stuff
so it's like weird like we actually i
ordered something on amazon like three
weeks ago next day delivery
don't still have it
sharon's like do you want to reorder
that i'm like well yeah it worked so
good last time let's do it again do it
again so i mean there's a lot of this
stuff is just out or these people are
backed up and they can't get it's wild
hey we're gonna ship it so if you need
something for christmas we'll ship it to
you just buy it it'll work you know hey
check out the biggest black friday sale
yet at our online store at
ramseysolutions.com
austin's with us in salt lake city and
uh hey austin what's up
hi dave thanks for having me on it's a
pleasure to speak with you and your
principles have changed my family
i'm calling in because my wife and i
recently had our first baby yay
what'd you have
we had a little girl oh
little girl daddy's in trouble
oh yeah it's been it's been great
it's amazing being a dad um
we've kind of asked our parents though
more for cash for her instead of toys
for the holidays coming up good luck
with that
yeah i'm not a huge noisemaking toys
guys so we'll see what happens but yeah
grandfathers are so i'm just saying
yeah we'll see we'll see what she opens
up on christmas morning but
we're hoping to and figure out we were
gifted some money when she was first
born we're hoping to invest it
and i tried to set up a 529 and it got
to all the options of
different funds and things like that
that i can invest and i i frankly am
just hoping to figure out what sort of
um investment i should put the money in
that we do get for her oh sweet good for
you yeah that's cool man good for you
yeah just jump online at
ramseysolutions.com and click smart
vester to get your college fund set up
and they'll say they'll help you set it
up it's not hard at all we spread
college funds like we do retirement
across four types grow of mutual funds
with long track records growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international that's what my children's
uh
college fund was invested in
and uh and it's and that's what my
personal retirement has invested in and
so not telling you to do something i
wouldn't do and by the way it worked out
okay my little girl's 37.
and i guess one of my questions would be
so
my wife and i are debt-free
but i plan on doing professional school
a medical degree so we will not be
investing into it ourselves where we
we're trying to figure out a way to do
it that free but we probably won't be
putting in anything other than what we
get each year for gifts and things like
that that's fine with that and it's just
fine for now and then later on when you
get past the school and you got your
income then you can go that direction
yeah you'll be just fine perfect hey
thanks for the call man i appreciate you
you're way out in front brother so um i
was listening to the
entree leadership podcast
this morning
on my run
and lo and behold dr john deloney is
giving advice on the um
holidays uh-oh of what to do
and um i discovered that you and i share
yet one more trait
neither of us are fans of the hungry
hippo game oh gosh talk about loud stuff
that grandparents brought kids the game
is pointless
and it's like you can't can you even buy
it still oh we got it our kit you got
new one you didn't get it at a garage we
got it and i'm looking directly at you
mom thanks we're real we're real excited
about it
yeah we got it and then it was a
grandparent yeah yeah that's what i was
thinking of when i heard you say that i
think the game was no you didn't say
that it was invented by parents who
wanted to torture their children who
just had their first kids yeah it's
payback yes what's the allowance oh you
give your you give your grandson
a drum set yeah yes or like hey here's a
foghorn son
yes shoot [ __ ] love this in the
morning here's the loudest possible horn
that you can blow i'm getting old now
blow it boy come on sun blowing i'm
gonna get my nieces and nephews cowbells
and all kinds of loud noises i'm just
telling you it's um but yeah hungry
hippo is
it's about as lame as rock'em sock'em
robots because you could the robot would
hit him right in the jaw and it didn't
hit yeah he didn't pop his head up until
you had it he had to hit him with the
thing about the thing about rocky didn't
work well no but your bad design on the
robots when you're hitting it
you can feel like you're hitting the guy
in front of you with the hippos it's
just
i don't know and then my daughter wins
and i don't have
the psychology for that it's a mess
well and
the problem too is this
[Music]
it's just teaching children wrong
because well all the hippo stuff is cute
and cuddly
even the hungry hippos you're cute and
cuddly and the cartoons they're all
wearing little hey really those are mean
man and the in the real
when you're in africa
you should be more afraid of a hippo
than a lion is that true i think i heard
that it kills me people the lions hippos
yeah they are vicious freaking animals
so there you go just a little little uh
little school of knowledge that you
didn't think you're gonna get from the
ramsey girl okay
thank you hasbro
ruined we're ruining our children but
loud toys
this is i think i'm gonna go get a bunch
of them for the grandkids i had not
thought of that as payback you've
inspired me dude i'm gonna go get a
bunch of those those horns
well i got there's a couple of them
there's like a flute thing
the potato thing or whatever it is oh
yeah the what do you call the recorder
recorders oh god everyone's one left
over from some kid and it's in the
grandkids playroom and they come out in
the middle of the all the adults and
that thing will blow your brains out i
love it it's like give me that
you know it's like yeah i think dave
this could be your your greatest
christmas ever for about 37 you can
laugh harder than you can
in the last calendar year
pay back you can go
to target and do all of your christmas
shopping the evil side of papa dave is
coming out
every kid gets a recorder i don't know
how great grandkids are gonna be i've
been nicer to their parents but now i
know yet another way to get their
parents
yeah just mess with them pretty excited
about that this is this is fun this is
gonna be great yeah i i kind of vowed i
was gonna be all responsible until they
got to about three years old and then
they knew what the toys were
and then um my older my children had to
set boundaries with me
because i
christmas was overwhelming because i
went i just lost my mind
and um there was just stuff everywhere
but it's so fun though well it was like
no money but it was just stuff i mean it
was just the whole this pile and the
little kids are just they're emotionally
overwhelmed so it was
you know i was the only happy one in the
room you know the kids are my kids are
overwhelmed the parents are mad because
i violated boundaries everything else
and so now i just have to get like one
toy
boo
fun ruiner could be loud yeah just wait
i'm gonna get him a bassoon can i how do
you like that kids i wonder if amazon
can overnight a hungry hippo or a
trumpet oh yeah they can get you a
hungry hippo man i can't get this other
stuff i ordered but they probably can
get that
i wonder supply chain got hungry hippo
you just never know
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm talking about my children my
grandchildren being annoying with a
recorder and uh during the break it was
discovered and played on youtube
that uh dr john dolone had actually
played a recorder to be annoying on his
own show and that is now featured on
youtube and now has been featured on the
ramsey show on youtube during the break
so i i made some comment about teacher
teacher
educators or like music teachers
and somebody on the internet's heard it
wrong and wrote me a real me like how
dare you belittle music teachers
i was like no man like i love music
teachers look at this i can still dave
i'm not gonna lie i'm incredible on the
recorder no you're not i just heard it
[Laughter]
i'm sounding like fingernails going down
a chicken boy i'm not great i'm not
great like one of my grandkids i wanted
to smack you
it was awful i'm not great at the
recorder i'm not yeah i gathered that
and so whatever music teacher was in
your life failed you if your kid is good
at the recorder dave wants you to
personally send him a direct message on
instagram no no not even anything good
or not i just i don't want any of it
it's uh send it all to
dr john deloney at ramseysolutions.com
it's his personal email address
all right
game on my friend game on
it's not really but you can try if you
want it i'm sure the spam will catch it
all right aaron and kamani kamana is
with us in maui hawaii hey guys how are
you
hello hi dave aloha says on my screen
you guys are debt-free
yes we are way to go how much did you
pay off
76 000
i love it how long did this take
uh 23 months rocking it and what was
your range of income during that two
years uh 132 to 167 000. you're rocking
it cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a general contractor and i am the
head fundraiser for a non-profit
very good what kind of debt was the 76
000
uh it was irs it was seven credit cards
it was a p-lock and a car loan you know
kind of normal
so normal
wow how long you been married
eric we've been married 11 years
together for 16. okay cool so what
happened two years ago they got you
hooked up with this whole ramsay thing
um well i had to humble myself that a
guy from tennessee had you know some
info that was worthwhile for a girl from
maui to listen to
um maui people aren't arrogant
no just me
humility pill
and we bought a house in 2010 we got
married in 2010 we bought a car in 2010
and we had a baby in 2011. it was early
in our marriage and it really just
stressed us from the start
and
we really thought that we could out earn
our stupidity and entitlement
and i was facing a
job change
in early 2020 so in 2019
i was tracking i kept looking at the
numbers i kept trying to figure out how
we could get ahead and i thought getting
a job making more money was the answer
and
shout out to the maui mommy's facebook
group people kept recommending this dave
ramsey guy and
so i clicked on and i looked and um all
of the information was there it was easy
it was elegant and it was free
which we really really appreciated and
um
i i don't know my husband would probably
say i kind of got a little obsessed
oh you went the other way
the pendulum swung from
i went all in yeah to drink the kool-aid
okay
wow good for you guys
okay
so aaron did she get a little obsessed
uh just a little
you were checking her
history on her computer like who's this
guy in tennessee she keeps talking about
oh yeah
all day every day
i'm sorry
but it worked
it worked so you guys got you got the
information and then what happened
what'd you do to get out of debt
um we
just i had been tracking all of our
expenses mainly just our big bills but
it was the little things in between that
was really killing us it was um
just getting into eating out it was the
small things it was a death by a
thousand cuts and trying to pay off our
debt all at once you know putting a 25
here on this credit card or we would get
a chunk of cash and throwing it on this
and then we would just spend it back up
so we really embraced the snowball and i
have to say it was hard at first to
learn and to change the patterns of
behavior that we had
and it you know we kind of stumbled the
first few months but kind of january
2020 it was kind of game on and then the
pandemic hit
and that really helped us luckily we
stayed employed and couldn't go anywhere
and couldn't spend any money so we just
i
just was on every dollar all the time
running scenarios seeing how fast we
could pay off the debt and aaron just
looked at me and said
we'll be fine we just stick to the plan
it's gonna be okay
wow good for you guys i'm so proud of
you well done
well done so have you had a month where
the check deposited and you didn't owe
anybody any money
and you just look at that balance and
think whoa
i feel so rich yeah it feels good huh
the way to go you guys way to go who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
we kind of kept this close to the vest i
have to say we had uh you know humility
is a big part of our journey and staying
hungry and
we shared it with family and friends and
they really encouraged us we had a few
older family members reach out and say
you know i wish i would have gotten out
of debt sooner you guys are on the great
track but this was really a journey for
us to um
get close again and
you know we just needed it was it was
like therapy for us it was
the journey was really a transformation
for the two of us
you're free yeah
it's incredible and in hawaii the high
cost of living
so many of our friends are living are
leaving
and um
we can do it you know hawaiians can be
in hawaii we can stay we can raise our
families we can do it and um i hope i
hope other folks here in hawaii hear us
or anyone that lives in a high cost
living area that you can do it you just
have to be humble and hungry and stick
to the plan
it's incredible powerful very powerful
and shout out to the maui mommies
and do you do you have little ones
we do a
ten-year-old and eight-year-old
ten-year-old and eight-year-old
and they're gonna get to see a new
picture of what a relationship looks
like of what marriage looks like when
everybody's on the same page when
everybody's not stressed about money and
that will change their biochemistry
and they will slowly lean into their new
relationships as they get older with a
new picture because you all did this
hard work
way to go it's incredible
now you guys are heroes that's beautiful
absolute man wow well done well done
all right well we got a copy of the
legacy journey we'll send out to you
that's the next chapter in your story
you'll be on moving on to be baby steps
millionaires next
and uh then also a copy of the total
money makeover maybe you can pay it
forward send it over to the maui mommies
let them raffle it off in the on the
website or the blog group or whatever it
is so i'm honored to be uh mentioned
there never been mentioned in a maui
group that i knew of before so you never
know where
where a hillbilly you're going to turn
up dave you're a big deal with the maui
i'm telling you it's a hillbilly turn up
it's a hillbilly shout out right there
life's good so uh my cool factor just
went up to a tiny little bit i could
agree to disagree but go ahead
all right aaron and uh let me see if i
can get this right kamana
kaimana kaimana
i knew i was gonna mess it up kaimana
aaron and kaimana
in maui hawaii 76 000 paid off in 23
months making 132-167
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
ekolu elua ekahi
[Music]
[Applause]
love it dave they got their marriage
back
we could have talked to him for another
hour they got their marriage back big
deal
big deal
and that's incredible
happens all the time when people start
working together towards a common goal
and they're both willing to sacrifice
their selfish interest to hit the common
goal yep whatever the common goal is
that's right whether it be uh
straightening the kid out or
straightening the checkbook out
but we got a common goal and we're not
willing to give up our own little
selfish interest to hit the common goal
that's good for the whole house
all of a sudden ding ding for their
neighborhood for their culture for
everybody stuff starts happening when we
grow up it's awesomeness well done you
guys i'm so proud of you you're heroes
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america we're glad
you're here dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five bill is in south
bend indiana hi bill welcome to the
ramsay show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey i just gotta know if uh dr delony
and james ever get a chance to get their
guitars out and help make some of the
music for some of the podcast
um james is not that good uh let's be
honest
um
i would love to
uh i'm just kidding james is way way way
better than me answers i was gonna fix
that if you didn't james is
the only thing we don't permit here is
this level of lying he's 10x better than
me but no they don't let us do that kind
of stuff together we do have a battle of
the bands here every year that is
absolutely amazing and both of them were
in
bands that lost this year so the same
band oh wow
we joined forces and they dressed up
like 80s metal with hair and everything
it was fabulous they were just
a bunch of clowns all right how can we
help bill i'd love to see that okay my
question is whether or not you think
that my wife and i are too heavily
invested in real estate and not heavy
enough in other investments
so here are the stats i'm 45 my wife is
41 our household income is 104 plus
dividends
from our business uh plus about 30 000
uh from
our airbnb and so this year we're
looking at it will probably be close to
230
that we'll make we've got
about 60 000
in our roth iras and
mutual funds and as far as the real
estate is concerned um it's all one big
piece of real estate so it's where we
live
it's our main house
it's uh got 38 acres what is your what
is your property worth
uh the property is worth probably
between 850 and 900 and we paid for
it we owe 165 on it okay and you're uh
do you own other real estate other you
own an airbnb or is that on the property
the airbnb is on the property okay so
you don't own any other real estate
that's correct okay and so your net
worth is over a million but almost all
of it's in this property
that's true
okay
all right it's a little lopsided but
it's not the end of the world it's not
going to cause you to not prosper the
property is going to go up in value it
is a pile of money that's not making you
much money
right
other than the appreciation and so
uh you know before i do a bunch of
improvements on that property add
another airbnb as an example on that
same property or something like that i'm
going to make sure i'm putting a good 15
of my household income into retirement
baby step 4
level every
month and i'm going to be working down
these mortgages so in other words i
wouldn't add to the real estate but let
the other stuff kind of catch up
uh and it will over time
i'm heavy in real estate i've got more
in real estate than i do in mutual funds
but i don't have
98 in real estate and that's about where
you're sitting it's getting pretty close
95
so
uh but part of the reason i'm so heavy
in real estate is i bought a whole bunch
of it for a quarter on the dollar in
2008 and then it shot way up
it recovered and then went up from there
and so
the values um have shot up
so much faster than mutual funds since
2008 that i've made a lot more money
there so it's thrown the balance off
and i've been investing in this property
that we run ramsey out of which was is
a lot of concrete and stuff so yeah it's
okay real estate it's not a bad place
you just want your money to be making
money and that money's not making a lot
of money right now so but it's not worth
saying oh you're stupid you need to sell
it's a horrible idea no i mean you're
just you just got a lot of money tied up
it's unusual and i would
i would not i would not make it worse
let me ask you something um on this last
call he mentioned that he's got a
business that he takes home a salary
from but then he pays himself dividends
against that i mean on top of that
salary and the dividends were high why
would somebody why would you do that
with your business versus just paying
yourself a higher salary the way it is
or is it semantics in effect the same
thing okay
the same thing i mean it depends on how
he's got depends on his corporate
structure but more than likely it's just
he's bonusing himself profits out okay
and they're calling them dividends there
may be a little bit of a tax move there
um unless he
i hope he's not in a sub in a c court
but he could be in a c court that could
be what he's doing all right ethan is in
elkhart indiana hi ethan how are you
i'm doing great better than i deserve
right yes sir how can we help i got a
another baby question for you i heard a
couple of those today okay
uh all right i'm looking forward to
being the first time father in february
yeah congratulations let's do things
right so we had uh
21 000 in our emergency fund i also
saved 3 200 my hsa so far the plan was
that 3 200 can help cover the hospital
bill
right well plans change like
always and we found out we're having
twins hey
yeah
so uh my question for you though is um
what i thought we could probably have a
affordable birth at you know three to
four thousand um
is now looking like my full deductible
twelve thousand seven hundred dollars
for the year
um there's a very good chance we'll meet
that um it's my wife's first first time
pregnancy and
um she's small uh high risk anyways
um
my question for you is
is it acceptable to
um take this as a payment plan when the
time comes
um no and use my
hsa funds to do that no uh because it's
tax you say no no
okay she says the only reason
the only listen when a hospital sends
you a bill it's due
the only reason they put you on a
payment plan is you can't pay the
bill you can pay the bill
it's just an income but it's not taxed
it's not
they don't they don't let they don't put
you on a plan because it's tax advantage
to you
they don't give a crap about that they
sent you a bill and it's due
okay and people don't pay it and they
put them on plans all the time but
uh no i would not do that i would just
pay the bill now what i would do is load
your hsa as full as you can load it
between now and then and i would go sit
down if you can get an appointment
in the world we live in with the
administrator of the hospital and say
what can we do to
pre-plan as much of this as possible
even pre-pay some of it
so that we can limit
the uh cost let me give you an example
of the type of thing i'm talking about
may not apply in your situation but
here's what's running through my head
sure on a traditional labor and delivery
if you're if you do not have insurance
at all
if you will go and offer to pre-pay
the labor and delivery or prepay 50 or
60 of it before the child comes you can
get a discount as much as 50
i'm uninsured and i'm willing to pay
cash but i'm going to pay a bunch of it
up front how much of a discount will you
give me i'm shopping hospitals to decide
where to have this baby
hospitals are competitive between each
other
to
forget have the only thing that anyone
is ever glad they went to the hospital
for yes which is a baby it's the only
positive time when we go to the hospital
right there's no other time we go woohoo
we're going to hospital right so uh you
know they love this is pr for them for
you to have a baby there
and so they will discount heavily in a
traditional labor and delivery for a
cash prepay
the question is how much of a deal like
that can you get because you got twins
on the way and you're not gonna be able
to cover it all out of the hsa and you
go i'd like to prepay some of this if i
if you'll give me a discount how much
can you help me out here first time dad
teach me how this works sitting with
someone in the administration's office
you probably are gonna get some kind of
help from them not because you're a
charity case but just because you were
intentional and proactive and they
probably would like having you around
and get that deal in writing and have it
include all of the doctors and all of
the stuff right yeah yeah so you don't
have a deal here but yeah man i love
that idea and they will work with you
work with you work with you yeah and you
can get you can make it that way you
don't just get your you might not get
the whole deductible hammer
and so it might be closer to your hsa
and less of your emergency fund that way
that gets dinged
in this but 10 years from today
we had twins it hit our deductible we
wrote a check
you won't even remember it no man and
this is i can't think of a better
quote-unquote emergency than hey we're
having another another kid right
most emergency funds are for when things
go sideways and you got an extra
blessing here man so yeah that's why you
have the emergency fund for just in case
absolutely and this is not about tax
advantage
not in this case so hey good question
congratulations proud for you man
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books good hour dr john deloney
good hour james child's good hour
geneseers on the phones for callie
daniels today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you can tune in to the dr john deloney
show as a podcast on the ramsey network
anytime you'd like it's unbelievably
popular
a huge amount of uh listenership on it
uh just out of the gate everybody's
loving this material all about mental
health all about wellness all about
boundaries and relationships and uh good
old grandma's common sense mixed in with
a couple of phds and so it works out
really good be sure you tune in and and
you can even call today make that part
of this hour if you want triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna start this hour with samuel in
california hi samuel how are you
uh better than i deserve thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
so i drive a 2018 accent in my parents
name and they co-signed it there's six
thousand one hundred fifty dollars left
and i can pay it off today
my dad might not like giving it because
he wants to buy me a new car loan which
i don't want but i think he'll give it
to me and my mom wants to give it to me
if i pay it off but how should we do the
car title transfer
and is there a gift tax
there should not be a gift taxes under
fifteen thousand dollars
uh the transfer
you would have to ask in the state of
california what the process is for the
transfer on a gift
um
in a lot of states you just put a dollar
on it and you gift it over
because it's inside the family
uh your you know your parents to you now
if i gift a car to someone outside the
family they may want to minim they may
want to put a value of the car on it
because the title transfer usually has a
tax associated with it in most states
and the tax is based on the amount of
the dollars the value of the car at the
transfer so
california i'm going to guess is going
to figure out a way to tax you they do
on everything else
so um but i don't know what that is so
you would just call
uh the department of motor vehicles ask
how you transfer a title where a gift is
involved
and uh have them give you instructions
on that um or you know hit their website
they may have an faq
that will tell you that you do need to
have a firm before you start writing a
check
to pay off a car
that is not in your name
uh you need to have a firm agreement
with your dad
since it's in his name i mean you're
talking to your mom about this but
obviously dad's not in the loop he wants
to get another car payment answer that's
no i'm not going to
um so
what i'd like you to do is just allow me
to pay this off and you title it to me
because i'm the one that paid for the
car
and that would be the morally correct
thing for him to do and i think he will
but you need to have that
clear you don't want to pay it off and
then him go okay let's trade it that's
your only option bubba
and uh you've got your money in a car
that's not in your name and this is a
deal you shouldn't have done in the
first place but
it's the best way to put this deal to a
close yeah i'm with you i i think you
sit down and have a grown-up
conversation with dad and you're going
to make some grown-up decisions and pay
off a grown-up car and i think this step
one is being honest with old man and
having that conversation i love it yeah
you got to be forward
it sounds like you guys are dancing
around him because you're like
negotiating with your mom so she
negotiates for him and that's more like
a 13 year old yeah instead of a you know
uh it's like you're trying to get
no you just need to sit down with the
players this is adult to adult and
everybody emotionally accept where we
are now your dad accepts that you're an
adult you accept that he's an adult
and that he doesn't have power over you
except this bad deal and let's also lean
into he's trying to help in the best way
he thinks he's trying to get you another
new car yeah he's not trying to hurt you
but what he's offering is not a good
idea a good idea that's right anthony is
in pittsburgh anthony how are you
i'm doing well dave long time listener
first time caller honored to have you
how can we help
well i have a question about some stocks
and if it makes sense to cash those out
and put that towards paying off my
student loans so i've been pretty lucky
in that
all i have as far as debt is student
loans i have about 58 000 in student
loans and i've decided that i just want
those gone so last month i made a ten
thousand dollar student loan payment
brought my savings down to just the one
thousand dollar emergency fund and i
have about
i have about 2 800 a month that i can
put towards paying off that debt um
because i'm fortunate enough that i'm
staying with a family member but i don't
overstay my welcome so i just want to
get out of debt as fast as i can so i
have about 10 000 in stocks that i've
incurred just kind of over the last
three years here here and there kind of
not managing my money well
and i'm wondering if it makes sense to
just
cash out what i have in that and take
all that money and put it towards just
paying off the debt that i have or if it
makes more sense just to keep keep that
and then just only use my income and
just continue to try and do what i'm
doing and paying off my debt
monthly
the shortest distance between where you
are
and wealth
is not a ten thousand dollar stock
account
it's being debt free
okay okay so i guess that answers my
question so just cash it out and put it
off paying off the debt as fast as i can
that'll get you where you want to go the
fastest
okay
in essence that's the question we're
always asking ourselves which way which
of these gets me to wealth the fastest
the ten thousand dollar stock account
and use my income or to be debt-free and
have all of my income to build wealth
with
yeah and that's what i was thinking and
i was just kind of going back and forth
i was like does the interest that i'm
paying on the loans is that you know
taken from the difference from what my
gains are on the stocks and my heart
told me no just cash it out in payment
but like the math side of me said just
solve a plan brother just follow the
plan yeah that's exactly right awesome
yeah this is what we teach yeah when
you're on baby step two you cash out
everything that is not retirement any
assets you have that are not retirement
and use them to get yourself out of debt
in baby step two and you throw every
dollar out of your budget you can add it
to baby step two and the reason is your
most powerful wealth building tool
is your income
all the data we have on millionaires all
the data we have on wealth building
is the the
the typical person that becomes a
millionaire in their 30s and 40s and 50s
does so by utilizing their income not by
giving it to someone else in the form of
debt it's that clean and that simple and
that's why
the ramsey brand has beat the debt free
drum for 30 years
not because debt-free but debt-free so
that
you can be outrageously generous
debt-free so that
you can invest because when you don't
have any payments you have
money lots of it man
it's it's so primitive and so simple and
so profound and so life-changing once
you get your hands on it and you just
never get away from it then you just go
why didn't i think of that
you know i've made a really good living
peddling common sense
i love it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host well it's almost time for
christmas
and some of you when you hear that word
christmas doesn't mean happy holidays it
means stress
uh i'm gonna pay for all the food am i
gonna pay for the travel how am i gonna
pay for the presents
but it doesn't have to be that way when
you have a plan for your money you can
have confidence even when everything
else seems out of control financial
peace university will teach you how to
put together a plan and control how to
get out of debt how to save money how to
build wealth how to be outrageously
generous it's christmas
average household when they're going
through this over 90 days pays off or
saves 2 700 and pays off 5 300 in debt
that's an 8 000 turn in the first 90
days
financial peace university is available
as a part of your ramsey plus
membership
you don't have to live with a stressed
out christmas
make 2020 the year you finally start
winning with money
go to financial peace university give it
as a gift join it at
ramseysolutions.com
fpu ramseysolutions.com
fpu ronda is with us in phoenix hi
rhonda how are you
hello gentlemen i'm fine thank you so
much for taking my call are you well we
are how can we help
yay okay so uh we have absolutely no
debt we own two homes one in arizona and
one in um florida we own four cars no
debt way to go right
right so my father just passed away in
june and i am the beneficiary of his
estate
which means that i got about four
hundred thousand dollars cash wow so i
have it split in two credit unions um to
protect it from you know insurance and
can see you at ncua
but i don't know what to do to
you know invest it safely or i am at a
loss of what to do okay all right what
are your other investments in do you
have other investments
um my husband's retiring from the city
of los angeles so he has a pension and
he has about 340 000 in deferred comp
and we have that in the conservative
profile and that's the only investment
you have
yes besides the real estate that we have
yeah got you and how old are you guys
um
mid 50 good very well good done good job
okay well when you if you're 100 debt
free you're on what we call baby step
seven
and when you get a
uh
found money uh a big check of some kind
uh as a high net worth individual which
is where you are
i always remind people whether they're
nfl superstars or whether they're rhonda
in phoenix
that and or whether it's dave and sharon
ramsey uh there's three things you can
do with money and you should always do
all three
number one you can invest it number two
and you should
number two
you should enjoy it
and you should
and number three you should give it
and you should
so i would first earmark what percentage
of the money that's coming in is going
to go to each of those categories um and
you can decide i don't care but just you
know i'm gonna put this percentage
towards uh lifestyle there's a few odds
and ends we want to do we want to spruce
up the house we want to buy a classic
car i want to go on a trip i don't care
uh and you know say we're gonna i'll
just make up a number you can decide
later if it's the right number i'm not
suggesting it but as an example we're
going to spend 10 percent of this on fun
so that's 40 000 bucks
fun okay okay we're gonna invest
sixty percent of this
and we're gonna give thirty percent of
this and we don't have to do it
instantaneously in one check
but we've just earmarked it for that so
that when we spend the money on
ourselves we don't feel guilty and we
don't feel like we're out of control
when we invest the money we don't feel
selfish and when we give the money we
don't feel like oh gosh did we do
something wrong or we did we give too
much or did we not give enough you
decide all of that ahead of time
put those dollars in different three
different buckets
in your mind the money's already gone
now you've all just got to actually do
the transaction so that it is gone so it
might take you two years to spend that
forty thousand dollars on yourself it
might take you three years to give away
the portion of the generosity it might
take you uh six months to make a
decision on your investing as far as the
investing goes i personally would just
tell you either to buy some real estate
that you pay cash for if you love real
estate or
buy some mutual funds which is what i do
i do those two things and so if you're
gonna sit down with a good if you're
going to do some investing in mutual
funds it doesn't sound like you've got a
lot of background in that you would sit
down with a
a smart investor pro go to
ramseysolutions.com click smart vester
you'll find the people we recommend
they'll sit down with you and start
learning about mutual funds because
we're about to put a big chunk in mutual
funds here
but the big thing here is make the
decisions ahead of time before the money
leaves it keeps all the emotions and the
regret and the
financial hangover from happening you
don't do stress spending or you don't
feel
weird about daddy's money went to this
or that
yeah and i would
maybe the giving portion is something
that you and your dad shared in common
right that was something that was
important to both of you and that that
can be a way you can honor that money
there and go have some fun with it i
love that and a good thing to always do
john
i think is
um
you know dad obviously did pretty well
yeah and i always just think of dad
sitting in heaven
does he like this
am i doing something that he'd be proud
of yeah with this generosity with this
expenditure
you know dad always liked such and such
and he always wanted to go to africa so
we're going to africa and we're going to
spend
20 000 bucks on a three-week trip or
whatever i don't know what the number is
but i mean and dad would be proud of
that you know our dad would you know
it's his legacy
and so you just think about is this
something that would make your daddy
smile yeah yeah i'm going to pass along
to our kids it's going to help them yeah
smile you know exactly and make him
smile too because his legacy keeps going
so the fact that you didn't just waste
it all
with no plan or intentionality very
seldom is that honoring to the person
who left it to you almost never but how
wise are you he passed in june
and you immediately put it in an account
and the credit union just walked away
from it for a season that's that's
brilliant good good for you yeah good
move yeah
trish is with us in fort worth texas hi
trish welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
dave appreciate it sure
um all right so just to jump into it my
husband and i are trying to figure out
in the next five years it makes any
sense for us to start
buying into some family property that my
parents own
um there's currently a large house on
the property and then a good-sized
guesthouse
the plan would be that in five years we
would potentially move out there take
over the large house my parents would
move to the guest house
and we would start paying them um you
know monthly and start accruing equity
in the property
um and so and part of that because we
have a baby the school districts out
here are a lot better than where we
currently live
um but is trying to figure out
financially that would be a wise move
for us we're currently in baby steps
five and six
and i will also say that the family
property is quite leveraged my parents
just replied just put we did a refinance
but there is some decent debt on the
property as it stands
are you there dave yeah i'm just um
i
i don't like this there's no way i'm
doing this yeah you don't own anything
you don't own anything so even if we
would
correct so even if we
and the thought to you so we currently
own a house for relive is that we would
put some equity in up front
but you don't own anything it's in their
name and it's leveraged
well we would uh
you know get some
with a consult with like a estate
planner and all of that so that we would
yeah but you can't the title you can't
change you can't split this title up
it's leveraged
gotcha okay you don't own anything
so as long as there's a more there's
debt on it there's just that well
they're not gonna be able to put the
title in your name
okay because they they have to pay off
the mortgage to put the title in someone
else's name i guess they could carve off
ten acres in the house not unless
there's a not unless there's a release
clause in this mortgage and there's not
so they have to refinance again the
whole thing yep
um okay so how much property is involved
um 13 acres so it's not huge 13 acres
yeah
hypothetically if it was paid for you
could subdivide it and the partial that
you're going to live on they could
actually title it to you
you could put the money into that
and they could owner finance the
difference which i still probably
wouldn't do but at least that way
there's some semblance of protection but
no you can't just write checks for
somebody else's property that's very
unwise
you're just asking for trouble
no
no please don't do this you're gonna do
it anyway please don't do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
ryan is with us winning the best dressed
debt free scream award ever yes ever
ever
ever
brother
never
never had a full-on show it is usually
people look like you're ready to break
out in a frank sinatra song right now
man i'm just saying i mean i figured if
you're coming to do your debt free
scream why not look like a million bucks
right thank you
everybody yes
dress for success i'm just saying look
at you man where are you from pittsburgh
pennsylvania awesomeness how much have
you paid off
i paid off 120 thousand dollars that'll
work and how long did this take you 17
months wow and your income during that
time i went from 45 000 all the way to
140. whoa what do you do for a living
so i
am at a dj weddings on the weekends um i
work uh for non-profit i'm an i.t
consultant
so full-time salary with them and hustle
like
i hustled like none other this this last
year yeah so is this the dj look
it is so uh
you got a great got a great set of pipes
thank you thank you look i'm just saying
man this is i bet you i bet you're
making some money doing that yeah yeah
so i go by dj double oh seven so this is
kind of like my beautiful it's even
better well played man well done
that's awesomeness well very cool well
thanks for dressing up for us man yeah i
appreciate it it's an honor to be here
very cool what kind of debt was the 120
000 uh 20 000 to the irs and a hundred
thousand to sallie mae student loans
that's simple how did you get 20k into
the kgb
so double 007
so um oh you're a small business that
you can pay taxes on exactly yeah yeah
okay so uh yeah i started out um
you know i was one of the borrowed
future casualties right i went to
university of michigan right out of high
school um out of state
um
and yeah that was the thing to do right
just go to the best school you get
accepted to
what's your degree in
uh i didn't get a degree so i was there
for four years
you know just signing papers taking
whatever classes i could to stay
enrolled had no idea what i wanted to be
when i grew up
you know four years went by like that
and
uh
burned out dropped out never went back
um and left with uh 80k in debt and 20k
accrued an interest over the years and
um so yeah i
you know just started to fly under the
radar over the years you know just being
self-employed
and just letting that
interest accrue and just you know taxes
on my you know unpaid taxes on income
so
yeah i discovered you in
2006 started listening to your radio
show
you know i got choked up any time i
would hear a debt free scream and i was
like man that'll be me someday once i
get the get the right job but you know
i'll wait on it um even tried to you
know throw 200 bucks a month at my at my
loans at the time but that was barely
covering interest i got discouraged
jumped off the wagon
fast forward to
2015
got a good job like okay i'm back on the
wagon took financial peace university
bought my next car in cash started
ubering got excited lost the job about
six months later or so got discouraged
jumped off the wagon again
finally 2020 rolls around
i've been djing for about four four
years or so making good money and i'm
just like all right this is good but i
can do more i can finally you know hit
some goals this year so i was like all
right let me get a let me get a
full-time job so i got a salary job on
top of my weddings
and i was ready to rock and roll
boom cove it hits no more weddings all
of my hustles stop yeah you know no more
no more ubering no more weddings no more
dancing
dance destruction it was just all came
to a halt so it got kind of discouraged
but um
you know what covid was the wake-up call
i never knew i needed
and i suddenly became really aware of
my mortality
and
i was like wow what would i regret
if i were to you know bite the bullet
this year and
you know
i was ready to commit to a three-year
plan you know prior to covet but
at that point i was like you know what i
want to do this as fast as humanly
possible
and i just waited patiently for the
opportunity to hustle again and sure
enough
end of the summer
wedding started to pick up again and
deliveries like absolutely exploded like
i
did every app you can think of uber door
dash you know grub hub just working all
the time
yes waking up 7 seven a.m driving before
work
driving during my lunch break driving
you know when i get off on the weekends
when i'm not wet you know you know doing
weddings so
just hustling as much as as humanly
possible i drove your income way up and
then you just thumped it yeah yeah
and i got so excited by the momentum
that i was doing that i was having that
yeah i just
got on fire man
so when people
hear the story and i love that it's so
real
it fell off the wagon jumped off the
wagon you said i like that better than
fellow i jumped off twice i
intentionally quit
two times and then i come back around
and then finally a little bit of
existential stuff hits and you go oh i
don't really want to be remembered for
this right so we got to get this knocked
out it's time to do this and
the mortality of cove it woke a lot of
people up to have some meaning to stuff
they're doing that's good it's a good
wake-up call and it's game on so now
people hear the story what do you tell
them the net net key is
to getting out of debt once you decided
to do it what was it
it is it's having the
the the big picture
um
[Music]
writing it down
absolutely um and seeing your progress
like paying attention to your money you
know whether you're using every dollar
or
another another app i mean one
one thing i've found helped me because
we live in such a digital age with you
know um
debit cards and such is just keeping a
digital register of every dollar that
you're spending you know just like you
advise people to to do so
yeah no matter what i spent like i'd
immediately would record it in my phone
like as i spent it so that i could feel
it even though we can't feel it with the
exchange like you always say but i could
feel something every time i could see
the number go down it was like so
that's important um so what was the
difference this time
because your income shot up after your
resolve
kicked in yeah not the other way around
the other two times when the income
dropped you gave up what's the
difference
uh the difference this time i think was
just the the wake-up call to mortality
and just uh
a bigger why a bigger why absolutely the
why
i need to do this is i became i've got
to do this right and i always thought it
was just so far out of reach even
planning i was just like oh this is
going to take me three to five years and
it always seemed like
you know
too far ahead in advance to plan but i
guess one thing about djing weddings is
i started having to plan my life like
years in advance like people are booking
you like one to two years in advance so
i'm like all right well if i know i'm
gonna be making this kind of money for
the next two or three years like why
don't i just [ __ ] down and sacrifice
and
you know
just get it out of my life and how does
it feel to be free it feels
amazing like i cannot describe it like
when i finally
paid off that lump sum
like i was just in tears for like
20 to 30 minutes like i was like i'm
gonna roll into a building on a tuesday
yeah in a in a tuxedo baby that's how i
feel a freaking deal
it's incredible man
well done very proud of you sir so
you're a hero you took control of your
life very well well done you changed my
feelings you didn't give up you didn't
give up man yeah that's it that's it
kept going copy of the legacy journey
that's the next chapter in your story to
be a baby step millionaire you're on
your way and a copy of the total money
makeover coming to you as well for you
to give away and light somebody else's
world up so absolutely you got a lot of
style man it's an honor to have you very
well done to be here very well done ryan
dj
dj007
in the tux to do the debt free scream i
love this guy you're getting married in
pittsburgh we got so fun yeah apparently
we got apparently we got the best dj on
the planet here this is awesome 120 000
paid off at 17 months making 45 to 140.
count it down ryan let's hear a debt
free scream
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go
there you go baby whoo
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 20
verse 7
some trust in chariots and some in
horses but we trust in the name of the
lord our god
bill bradley said ambition is the path
to success persistence is the vehicle
you arrive in
oh that's
no doubt about it no doubt about it
perseverance is
the thing dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today hershey
pennsylvania up next jacob is calling hi
jacob how are you
hey guys how are you doing better than
we deserve what's up
so my fiancee and i are getting married
in may of 2022 and we are going to be
paying for the majority of our wedding
ourselves and i was just wondering
whether you would recommend one person
paying for the wedding uh maybe me and
my fiance is splitting it half and half
i know you probably don't suggest
opening a bacon count for the wedding i
was just wondering what your opinion was
on that
i don't mind opening a bank account for
the wedding and both of you and both of
you fund it and both of you have access
to it
this is a a venture that we are doing
together prior to being married and so
we can fund it
um i just wouldn't share all your
finances prior to the wedding meaning i
would i would share the knowledge of
them but not the transactions
uh don't act like you're married legally
before you are
get yourself in a pinch but um
so i i
i don't care who pays for the wedding i
don't know that there's a moral
thing here i mean you know if you want
to go old-fashioned uh the bride's
parents pay for it right that's
old-fashioned obviously that's not
what's going down here so uh why would
one of you or the other
bear more of the cost is there a reason
no there's no reason i was just
wondering whether it makes more sense to
take it out of one person specifically
or just to keep it half and half
seems like there's something else
underneath this question
because it i mean if the wedding goes
off then
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter
the following the following afternoon
yeah yeah i was just looking for your
guy's opinion
do both of y'all have the cash to fund
this wedding
yes
okay what do you make
um i make about 42. what does she make
about 35.
okay
uh do both of you have about the same
amount of debt
uh we neither must have bet
okay
sounds like everything's pretty equal
yeah we're pretty much on the same
territory as far as baby steps go yeah i
mean i guess you know it would like if
you call me up and you said uh i make
30 and my uh fiance makes 200.
um and she wants to pay for more of the
wedding i would go well that
mathematically kind of makes sense
uh but it's not like a moral obligation
or something wrong and john's right as
soon as you come home from the
uh from the ceremony the honeymoon
it doesn't matter anyway because it's
all combined at that point and
the net the net effect is exactly the
same after the wedding part of me likes
the idea of y'all too going to get a
checking account wherever you're going
to bank at your
as your joint account and she puts five
grand in you put five grand or whatever
you're paying for this wedding and you
all work from there and then that's your
account you close your two separate
accounts when when you're when you're
married part of me likes that and part
of me thinks man weddings are so
stressful
just somebody pay for this thing let's
get it over with sounds like six and a
half dozen another but yeah i don't know
it'd be okay if you fund it together and
i i'll go ahead and give you the other
piece of advice and that is weddings are
like anything else they're a project
and you should
do some planning on them
and set some set a budget and set a
boundary and say okay we're going to
spend x
and here's how much of x we're going to
spend on the photographer here's much
how much we're going to spend on the
reception here's how much we're going to
spend on the dress here's how much we're
going to spend on the preacher here's
how much we're going to spend on the
honeymoon and the total is the amount
that we're going to have in the account
not more not less we're going to have
spent the money and then if you get in
there and you go well the reception is
you know the reception
this the they want to put these flowers
out and the flowers are we can't they're
not in our budget well they're not in
the budget so we don't put them out and
so you know you have to have some
guidelines ahead of time because you're
going to bump up against a no
and if the no is not
brought to you by your plan
then it sounds like one of you is
deciding over the other one what's going
on and you go hey you can't do an 8 000
address we had 800 bucks budgeted for
the dress and that's what i don't like
because then it's well i'm paying for
the dress then and you pay for this and
then i'll pay and then now we're talking
division right yeah you got to have a
you need an overall budget that you
agree to for the project it's how you
build a house that's how you do a
wedding it's how you do anything that's
project based
is you start with the line item to
budget and then you know you may have to
make a few adjustments along the way but
we've got an agreed to value system
of what this wedding is going to be we
care more about the reception
than we do about the flowers yep so
we're going to put this more money on it
you know or we care more about the
flowers than we do about the reception
so we're going to put this money on it
and you decide that up front and then
when you get down in the emotion of
bridezilla or whatever picking stuff out
then it doesn't all blow up on in your
face or it shouldn't
if it does you got other issues
josh is with us in seattle hey josh
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave thanks for having me i'm
excited to be on with you we're honored
to have you how can we help
yeah so i am
actually a second generation uh
following your principles dave financial
success and i'm currently in a spot
where i am really wanting to buy a new
car i'm a natural spender and i've saved
up for it and with the craziness of the
market normally i would buy used but at
the price of the car and based on my
financial situation i'm wondering if
it's okay if i you know i celebrate and
move forward in that way are you a
millionaire
i'm not a millionaire yet then i
wouldn't buy a new car
okay
does the price of the car and the rest
of my financial situation matter though
no because you don't have enough net
worth to absorb the loss of a brand new
vehicle
okay you can buy it if you want to buy
it but i wouldn't
what's the value what car are you
talking about
yeah so it's a ford's new little pickup
truck it's like 22 000
okay
and i've got the cash saved up for it
plus rolling in my my current car's
value and
yeah
okay
and and your um
your your income is what uh my income is
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
okay
and uh how old are you
i'm 31.
okay all right so josh i can tell you
what i did uh
my wife
when we needed a new car
and
dave takes care of my family pretty well
and i went and bought a used car
and i did that about three weeks ago and
i walked on and wrote a check for a car
on the car lot down the street here
and
then i drove home and so that's what i'm
doing on my house man just and even if
it was five thousand bucks difference
between a 2018 and a 20 21 whatever the
thing was 2019 i don't know what year it
was
even if it is 3 000 500 i'm not gonna
give him that money not on a car like
that okay here's the thing the way
you're structuring your sentences and
the way you've asked the question
tells me you have a really bad case of
car fever
[Laughter]
you are really sucked in and in love
with this little truck
you have bought it you have driven it
you fantasized over it and now you're
rationalizing the purchase of it it's
going to give you muscles your hair is
going to grow back all the things you
know
it's you know
it's it's gonna make you sexy it's gonna
do all this and it's just none of this
is true it's a stupid little truck
and they all go down in value and you
can do whatever you want to do josh
you're a grown man okay but you called
and asked me
the rule of thumb that i've used for 30
years and it's served me well is don't
buy
a brand new
vehicle
because vehicles go down in value unless
you have a huge net worth
and the ability to accept the loss of
value
well with covet in the crazy car market
and i know
but they're going to go down in value
they're not going up
five years from now things gonna be
worth nothing and ten years from now
it's gonna be worth double nothing
and that's what they do that's what all
of them do
and so you just decide how much of that
you want to absorb
and um it's probably not gonna cause you
to go bankrupt it's probably not going
to hold you back that much
but it is a good rule of thumb to not
buy the largest thing we all buy that
goes down in value
to buy the worst possible scenario of it
going down in value which is brand new
unless you've got a large net worth to
absorb it it's that simple it's not a
principle it's just
arithmetic i just did it it's arithmetic
and so you but you can do whatever you
want son it's okay i mean we'll still be
friends
but i wouldn't advise
john good show today i agree and also
with you very well done and uh austin's
on the phones and james is uh running
the booth in there i'm dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you